truckstop diva hi I'm Nancy O'Dell
hi I'm Jane Pauley and I'm here to talk
to you about fun ways to incorporate
granola nope okay this part's improv bow
down [ __ ] I think so so make sure
whoever you date is it great with knives
well
Trixie a Scottie of something she's
always wanted to know about her oh how
dare you what gives you the right uh-huh
I'm have kids no okay
I would I would be like that hamster who
ate her children that's not like a
well-known 1:1 hamster did it you know
the old wives tale about one hamster my
family had a hamster date they date all
the kids you know why they do that
hungry yeah gee I would be like a fifth
generation plumber how is that huh but
my grandpa will come home and tell me
stories of him literally spending the
day be knee-deep in I don't know one
man's trash is another man's treasure we
could you sell ketchup to a woman with
white gloves which in makeup number one
sells I mean I know you need a pencil we
didn't have white gloves on so I can't
tell can you catch up do you like hot
wet feet call in
your future is about as clear as those
boots yeah look they're fogging up I
love that condensation I got hot seat
not a huge fan of smoking mmm you know
anybody who smokes I know yeah yeah
gusting
what about an alarm clock what do you
wake up it's Angie wake up
oh my say Alexa wake me up at 7:00 a.m.
with the circle of life by the original
Broadway cast The Lion King
so then I'm you know that I sleep like
hey hey I wake up - I mean that's great
because then I can't as I get out of bed
it sort of becomes like a sort of like
floor routine like a modern dance
yeah from the day we yeah I like so if
heaven is real I love Africa I've I've
always wanted to go I just think it's a
magnificent place which we're all life
peaking wonders of the world isn't
anything anyway sorry okay look at this
just see what's going on here this is
life because this is the the long hard
road right here oh oh it's been a long
hard dusty road it looks like a long
hard dusty road to hell don't you think
it smells that way - that's looking
pretty grim for a while oh that's all we
have time for I'm glad we got to know
you today thank you so much and I will
see you in the car in the car anyway
yeah on the way home yeah bye
[Music]